hey guys now this is another video
request and some of you asked me Daniel
how do you get a girl to like you please
give me some psychological tips and
tricks now this is not this is not
really a video that I would normally
make so this is going to be a very
interesting one and I'm gonna be very
honest and I'm gonna give you my tips of
getting a girl to like you let's get to
it
[Music]
[Music]
alright so let's jump right into it now
there's only two areas that you can
focus on to really get a girl to like
you right is the inner part and the
outer part the inner part is your
character your personality the outer
part is your looks your appearance and
just the way you carry yourself now
let's start with the inner part first
now there are five important things that
you need to know you got to focus on
being the right guy first there's a lot
of videos out there blogs as well to
just focus on these outward things these
psychological tricks that you need to do
to impress a girl to to get her to like
you and it's selling if you focus on
building yourself up to have a good and
confident character you'll automatically
do things that will attract the right
girl never just do cheap tricks just for
the sake of impressing a girl do it
because it is who you are remember a lot
of guys out there they just do things
they just pretend and then once they get
into the relationship they need to live
this life of pretending and that's not a
life that you want to live what you want
to do is you want to attract the right
kind of girl that will like you for who
you are
next up be a gentleman you know with the
type of world that we live in today you
will stand out by far if you are just a
gentleman and you know this is something
that you can learn and it started by
having respect for yourself
and for the people that you're with
Richard Branson said respect is how to
treat everyone not just those you want
to impress you know I've seen a lot of
arrogant guys out there to treat women
as an object as a thing a real man
treats a woman as a human being a lady
he has honor you gotta be you and you
gotta be honest a lot of these videos
and blogs they say oh you got to be
funny you got to be adventurous you got
to be full of confidence and so forth
well some of it do work but it it's got
to fit in with your personality if
you're more a serious type of guy and
you're bad at jokes then don't try to be
a comedian just be you and if you're shy
and nervous you're not really sure what
to say you just be honest
girls like that so you just say look I'm
actually a kind of shy guy so a little
bit nervous because you're so beautiful
and I don't really know what to say
that's what you do if she sees that you
are honest and that you know who you are
then that will also come off as
confident number four don't be selfish a
lot of guys just think too much about
themselves things like do I look good
enough I hope she likes my hair I got to
tell her how good I am at sport I want
to give her the impression I'm rich and
it just goes on and on and on and on and
sometimes these guys just talk about
themselves all the time you need to
shift your focus from yourself to her if
you're on a date for example think about
things like I wonder if she's cold maybe
she needs my jacket or I want to know
her better so speak less and listen more
or what are her hobbies or what doesn't
she like you see what I'm saying if you
put the focus on her a lot of girls like
that
and she will know if you asked all these
questions or if you care about it in
your manner in your way of speaking then
she'll know that you truly care about
her number five don't fear rejection
look it is gonna happen not everybody's
gonna like you not everybody likes me
not everybody likes everybody that's how
it is because we are all different so
don't fear rejection we're all different
and it's a good thing if someone rejects
you don't get this feeling or thought
into your head that I'm not good enough
you are good enough for the right type
of girl and here's the thing most of the
time when somebody rejects you it says
more about them than it says about you
because they don't really know you they
fail to see what you have to offer and
just the last advice don't rush to get a
girlfriend be patient and take this time
to focus on improving yourself all right
now that's the first part the inner part
what about the outer part well there are
a few things few basic easy simple
things that every guy can do to look
better and that success to this video
right here now if you're new to my
channel remember to subscribe so you
won't miss any of the next videos and if
you watch this video or this one and
I'll see you there
Church guys
[Music]
you